and this chill is I can possibly be at
this moment in time don't touch me
we want to make a Boston Dynamics spoof
parody video with this motion capture
suit we want to figure out how to do it
the best way possible the joints the
arms legs they need a like stick in and
still look mechanized in mechanical
we're gonna see if we can optimize our
motion capture workflow and make it work
for a robot that's important usually
when you're doing motion capture it's
for like bendy things like been dating
parts because there's either cloth or
skin but there's a robot no bendy things
we're filming Thursday we're trying foam
Thursday that's in three days
that gives us today to do some R&D
tomorrow to write Wednesday to prep and
then Thursday we shoot and we're gonna
try and see if we can't get two videos
out of this idea at all experiment with
the nulls Sam you can experiment with
the skeleton and see what we can come up
with in a couple hours or whatever
problem sewing I like this a lot because
I thinking about this over the weekend
of it where like you have someone who's
like 13 years old and watching Avengers
end game and they're like wow that's
what movies are and that's what cinema
is like just like this infinite world of
possibilities like where you don't need
cameras anymore you know it need sets or
like actors you just have like a virtual
camera in a virtual set and 3d models of
people and you just do whatever you want
no more filming a movie in your backyard
my first movie was in outer space does
not look like the matrix up in here 13
matrix II yeah we need that like one of
those things be lighting up to like
right here we need a head like
yeah well a red light so you can see it
reflect off of it that's moving Sam just
came up with a genius idea we're going
to mount like a camping light of sorts
to my head in the mocap suit and then
give the robot lights so it's actually
interacting with the environment around
it this is I'm so amped for this there
you go my favorite little lights these
little lucky lights are so great whoa
buddy a black light oh my but this would
be like enough light where it's like you
can actually there's a museum you see
Suzy I mean I could turn it up turn it
up yeah
lens flares are your murderous for
compositing though film is on the red
because I was thinking it could be cool
to use those like little camcorders the
camcorders yeah it's complicating our
workflow it would mark it might if I can
turn off this stabilization stuff I just
wonder if you can get it with the red if
you want to run some tests on it maybe a
little high it's about a guillotine
blade okay cool yeah I just wanted to
see if you guys had any questions or how
it was going come by probably on
Thursday this week okay all right thank
you take care bye
back to work that's it that's all you
get to know
I mean basically what we're trying to do
is match the mocap data over the top of
me in the footage and then paint you out
and take me out yeah so we're trying to
do that in a tripod shot where we
actually need to replicate the exact
position and focal length of the camera
we're shooting it on and we're trying to
do it in 3d moves which is you know 3d
track match with the shot I don't know
how to do it just yet there's the door
but that's not enough to align the whole
shot off then you make a corner
I need something out this on the ground
probably too quick for a quick one like
this corner would totally work you have
to do a frame you have the corners
basically I need as many lines as
possible on the wall on the ground to
align the camera it's important that we
get the camera as accurate as possible
in 3d space relative to him if he's
going to interact with objects it needs
to be super super super accurate so the
camera position relative to cam has to
be spot-on we have to get that down how
are you feeling about filming on
Thursday Sam what do you have a light in
your head the suits not connecting with
the program we're working on figuring
this out together
you got more research yeah I don't know
guys I mean all the stuff we're talking
about here are just like the fundamental
things that we need to figure out so
what you're telling me is like we just
need to figure out the fundamentals of
the entire program and the suit that
we're gonna use to film the video before
we film it it's actually pretty far
along we have a bunch of really great
ideas we have it so that the robot lines
up with its body now we just have the
final step of going let's just do a
simple shot where we have Clint being
filmed doing something like this and
replace them with the robot it's
actually pretty far along we have a
bunch of really great ideas interacting
with a single real-world object
and that's it because if we can't do
that we've just reached a limit you know
sometimes things get a little stressful
in the studio but I just came back from
Hawaii and the friend of mine
recommended I check out something called
kava kava I'm not quite sure I was
pronouncing we call it kaveh I have a
bag of it right here now this is
supposed to be like the opposite of
coffee its roots its roots straight up
pieces of root and it's a Pacific
Islander thing they come from Vanna tau
and so I guess you chew on this and it
makes you feel calm it chills you out
it's really anxiety I think this is a
good day to give everybody a little bit
of route they can chew on it they can
feel a little more chill it's fully it
sharpens the mind we'll see how it goes
let's get back to our roots everybody
holding onto his head hey guys I brought
you a gift of Hawaii it's a perfect time
for it right now this is a root thank
you it ginger yeah come on ginger or
carrot yes
or dirt not dirt you chew it it's gonna
chill you out a little bit it's gonna
sharpen your mind
do you like marijuana yes like the devil
look here wait a mo kit no you chew it
you guys are super stressed out right
now I'm not I'm not stressed out we're
really really focused and motivated
right now Jill is I can possibly be
at this moment in time I can tell by
your eyes that you are blatantly lying
to me I'm sure right now I'm sure don't
touch me I'm doing it you chew this
don't eat the bark like this in the
middle will kind of come out is to chew
it so just I got peanut shells it's
gonna make your tongue in your mouth
numb what how do I know it's both versus
doesn't like your saliva keep consuming
that as well because I'm gonna basically
extract the kava tones whatever they're
called
let the liquids come out of it over time
all the pulp will basically shoot out of
this the goopy meat is now sliding now
yeah the goopy meats what you want to
say this is awful
oh god I feel ill
without children loxias I do feel a
slight showing time I feel something I
feel sunbeams for real I don't know
people men were supposed to get this
chill I feel pretty chill the numbing
tingle is kind of going throughout my
whole body now I can't tell that's just
like my low blood sugar I'm good dude
I'm chilling I'm just checking out
what's in here cuz I was just looking a
pleasant numbness right now at my lips
like canyons yelling my head feels kind
of chill like the whole head
Nick was suppose to be the one filming
this chillin
dude it still tastes like a tree dude
this is like the most bitter no I did
not eat trees I don't eat trees where
does the bean bag come from I don't know
how much of it steve-o but I do feel a
little bit more I don't know like mom
chill takes the edge off I don't quite
feel quite as stressed I actually feel
like the focus part is is here now like
I feel just kind of like yeah I don't
know I feel like if I put a task in
front of myself I could focus on and
just be like that's right now I'm just
kind of Zen and how will this dictate
[Music]
what is going on around here Sam and
Clint are working on the video finally
writing it they're struggling with that
all day it's finally happening
friends at his desk quietly working got
Michaels plugging away I got no worries
looks like my duties here I've been
fulfilled whether now is the route I
guess our friendship the power of music
who knows but you have to go to this
quarter channel subscribe figure out
what it is that they're working on
consider subscribing to this channel too
it's a good choice make you feel chill
like you just need some copper
[Music]